tous
[Musique]
c'est certainement le meilleur condensé
d'histoire de france un château médiéval
entre béni et bourbonnais au beau milieu
de la france avec un logis renaissance
de toute beauté des jardins remarquables
et même une partie 19e le château des
navy elle a été en perpétuelle évolution
au coeur de l'histoire de france et
surtout conserver et entretenu par la
même famille depuis 14 ans 67 une
famille qui a engagé une réhabilitation
totale qui devrait se terminer d'ici
quatre ans
développer tout ce qui était hébergé
mans parce que on avait déjà des
mariages mais maintenant c'est compliqué
de conduire des km et 10 km donc avoir
un hébergement on en aura l'année
prochaine 50 de couchage ça permet aux
gens de profiter de l'endroit
tranquillement ici le mot d'ordre c'est
se sentir bien dans le parc au milieu
des jardins le parfum des roses nous
fait rêver retomber en enfance c'est
bien ça fait ça fait rêver quand on
était gosses on aimait bien jouer à
l'est avec les épées tout ça on
s'imagine on s'imagine des des gosses
couvrant là dedans des soldats
fait rêver coup d'autres contemple le
château et sont simplement ravi c'est
très beau c'est magnifique c'est
reposant c'est
super je le trouve magnifique oui oui
oui de jolis jardins
s'est entretenu c'est beau c'est quelque
chose à faire voir oui alors oui le
times a raison le château d'ainay viel
est un lieu à venir voir absolument
un lieu d'histoire de pierre de culture
un lieu de vie quoi que seul le bénigne
vous offrir